hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure Meinung
und willkommen zu einem neuen
Adventskalender auspack Video heute
packen wir den Kalender von Weinfreunde
aus und dazu habe ich meinen Lieblings
Weinfreund geholt Timo braunesh
Applaus Applaus meine lieben
ich hätte den Kalender alleine auspacken
können aber ich finde Alkohol trinken
wir sind Gesellschaft
und wir haben Eiswürfel ich weiß dass
man weinen eigentlich nicht mit
Eiswürfel trägt aber normal stimmt
Rotwein halt nicht ja aber die Weißwein
Keller wird aufgeregt in deinem Kalender
Videoformat mit drin bin stimmt
vielleicht wie läuft das ab wir packen
eigentlich du guckst dir die nicht an
ich frage ihn mal hast du das in meinem
Video gesehen und dann sagst du dran
nein noch zu viele einfach nur eine
Million ja aber 37 weit Folgen gehen
rein ich glaube wir fangen am besten
jetzt einfach mal an ne wir schauen ja
wir fangen mal rein bei den Weinfreunden
daher schauen wir rein 99 Euro kostet
der Kalender 4,10 € pro Türchen für Wein
finde ich ja es ist vino aber Brötchen
drin sein wahrscheinlich nee achso
gemacht habe ich noch so ein bisschen
ich habe nämlich Mittagsschlaf gemacht
ich war so ein bisschen entleerium und
dann habe ich ein falsch gemacht und
dann sind so ein paar Flaschen raus aber
ich konnte sie wohl wieder zurück
reinpacken das kann halt sein dass so
ein zwei Türchen so wurde schon geöffnet
ich gucke meinen Freunde zu und dann
sind diese das war gar nicht da drin das
war gar nicht da drin ich würde sagen
lass uns Vorglühen lass die spielen
parfügung
willst du willst du das erste Türchen
aufmachen habe ich die Ehre ja du hast
die Ehre dann würde ich sagen Numero Uno
große Fläschchen ne ich dachte das wäre
jetzt irgendwie so ein ach so stimmt ja
schon groß ich also schon mal das
Etikett gesehen
ich habe absolut keine Ahnung
überhaupt kein Rotwein Trinker gar nicht
ja aber ich denke jetzt wird hier also
ja
aber ich kann auf jeden Fall keine
Expertise abgeben
Flaschenöffner gucken danke
wie heißt du weiter Alonso Andrea Alonso
okay also die Flasche kostet 8 Euro das
heißt hier sind wir bei 4€
trinken
ja Bewertungssystem drei geben
Türchen Nummer 2 so jetzt kommen wir an
den Punkt ich hoffe das war wirklich
klein nicht mal Wein was kann das sein
weder
sein nein echt okay der war eigentlich
in der 23 drin also das ist eigentlich
asi richtig
und der kostet 12 Euro
3 das war so mega gut gemacht
oha ich bin wieder eine Big bottle
Weingut Düringer Baden Grauburgunder
trocken verfälscht
mit trinken sorry ich war jetzt wirklich
mal den mag ich scheiße wir haben gar
nicht gesagt Timo was bevor wir jetzt
die ganze Zeit Wein Freunde sein
Video ich kenn doch deine Videos dieser
dieses Video nicht gesponsert und jetzt
alle dieses Videos nicht gespannt
t ich ein bisschen verfälscht weil wir
dann ganz bisschen Rotwein drin hat
definitiv es sieht auf jeden Fall jetzt
aus wie ein Rosé ja für mich wie so ein
Wein
Sommern
okay der Geruch Bruder
brauchst du kleine Nase also Leute
können mir erzählen was einfach geiler
als Rotwein schmeckt einfach besser aber
ich mag Grauburgunder gar nicht mehr so
gerne ich dachte früher
dachte ich früher auch und dann habe ich
mal so ein richtig guten Chardonnay
getrunken und war so das schmeckt nach
Baguette ja kostet 7 sage ich aus dem
Stegreif schmeckt nach 7 €
ist doch klar du bist ja wirklich 95 600
€. das ist wieder die Hälfte das
bedeutet
du bist wieder dran
4 diese weingröße sollte sich
durchsetzen um einfach wenn wir uns zum
Beispiel abends im Wein kaufen würden ne
und eine Flasche mit 700 ml aufmachen
dann trinkt man voll viel das sind so
für jeden Glas ja ungefähr ernsthaft
trinkst du wahrscheinlich jeden Tag oder
bisher die ganze Zeit selber dauert
einfach zum Sammeln oder wie also jeden
Tag so eine Flasche der reinhauen 24
Tage Gl machen ja also können wir den
jetzt nicht testen aber wir gucken mal
was der kostet aber auch ein tolles
Label Wein sieht einfach schick aus
sechs Euro das heißt drei okay Leute
Türchen Nummer 5 wie stehst du denn zu
Adventskalender magst du Adventskalender
auf jeden Fall was schätzt ihr was ist
drin also ich würde jetzt gucken sie ja
sagen
Gott verdammter Kor
kenzieher den finde ich eigentlich gut
ich finde den besser muss ich sagen
ja ja und kostet 8 € Euro dafür
ein Türchen Nummer 6 was hat uns mein
Freunde in unser Schuh gepackt und oh
nein
die sieht mega cool das Versteck dich da
drunter also in dieser Flasche also lass
so okay das ist nicht echt noch
wie nennt man das denn Briefmarken ah
das sieht einfach aus wie du Briefmarke
ja das ist eine ganze Geschichte den
Raben dürstet sehr nach Wein dies könnte
sein Verhängnis sein hier ist eine ganze
Geschichte auf der Weinflasche drauf 20
fabelhaft duro Portugal ne dann müssen
wir uns wieder aufmachen keine Ahnung ob
der gut ist boah die Flasche kostet 9,50
€ gut das heißt es ist schon auch das
ist schon jetzt die gehobene Klasse oder
9,
4 75 Trockner Rotwein trocken genau das
auch immer noch wichtig eine trocken
stammt von bekanntesten weinpionier
Portugals Dirk niport
oder damit kann man arbeiten
nicht so wie mit deinen riechen
oh der riecht sehr bärig
das Geräusche
guter one hit viel besser als der erste
viel besser ja
würde ich jetzt quasi so beschreiben
präsentiert werden
2021 Rosé feinherb apfelbar abfülle
Andreas Hills oh danke der gute Andi
Mensch 96 ich bin ja ein Fan von dem
guten Rosé Berlin jedes Mal so viel
Einchecken bei dem mus
eum bei schnacken denke ich
immer ein bisschen rosea als er sein
sollte weil da natürlich wieder ein
bisschen Rotwein Rest drin war aber
sonst tolle Farbe
feinherb würde ich sagen oder süß
sehr lecker Rosé bin ich ein großer Fan
von beiden ja unterschreiben ja schmeckt
er dir 4,5
viel kaputt du bist aber auch immer sehr
Generalist ne ich denke mir so was soll
das doch
warte warte warte warte warte warte
Kühler für die Flasche ja oh cool okay
habe ich ja noch nie gesehen also man
hat seine Rose man sitzt draußen mit
seinen Freunden ne und äh hat eine
schöne Flasche Wein gemacht
sehr schlaue Idee 10 € kommen wir zum
Türchen Nummer 9 Timo das müssen wir ein
bisschen mehr zelebrieren du machst das
dahin in der hintersten Ecke auch das
ist für die Nummer 9 ist mein
lieblingstürchen man merkt man muss
nicht guckst das ist wirklich Türchen
nochmal nein Leute Nummer 9 drin der
beste Mann
sieht Französisch aus oder Espana 2019
der ist 3 Jahre alt timo ist echt cool
der ist 4 Monate im Eisfach gereift es
ist immer komisch dass in Türchen Nummer
9 ist entweder Polen drin oder und ich
kann meistens zu Türchen Nummer 9
relaten diese Weinerei wie heißt das
diesen Winzer gibt es einfach seit 1993
mein Geburtsjahr
auf bitte nicht nur 7 € die Flasche ich
dachte das ist jetzt hier so ein super
nicht aufmachen okay diesmal benutzen
wir den Schweizer Taschenmesser
reindrehen leute das ist genau die
Situation wo ich meinen da wird man ja
und mein mein Blazer auch ich muss mich
schützen ich habe euch Angst von dem
Pulli muss kurz zu ziehen nicht so oder
einmal Applaus für the walk it only der
riecht schon wieder ein bisschen herber
muss ich sagen
intensiver auf jeden Fall ne
geiles Geräusch oder
nee das schmeckt wie was was im Vater
trinken würde was der der zu strong
Herbert
das geht mir so ich mag und Kochen in
Türchen Nummer 10 befindet sich Rabatt
Stein
weißer Glühwein Leute weißer Glühwein
man kennt den man liebt ihn
fantastischen Flasche verstecken damit
Schaf geht Oma Trude
müssen wir auch mal machen denn es gibt
mir auch oder allein aber für Oma Trude
gebe ich schon mal vier Punkte
13 was ist das Prosecco
auf jeden Fall aber ich finde geile
Variante sagen schon geil
unterschiedlich da würde ich mal sagen
ich würde uns beide schon als Sekt
Profis beschreiben wir haben letztens
ein von Lidl gekauft
ihr könnt auch meditieren
lecker
ich mag so fruchtig aber für viele ist
ja glaube ich schon zu mild zu fruchtig
jetzt bin ich wieder dran
Türchen Nummer 14
Deckel ganz klassischer Deckel das ist
ein ganz klassischer aber sowas fehlt
uns noch
24 Stück
wir sind jetzt sehr weit gekommen ich
spüre schon eine leichte
döseligkeit weiter geht's natürlich hin
Nummer 15
Rotwein toll super toll
57 das heißt
3,5 €
muss jetzt eigentlich schon quasi es
gewinnen
du hast getrunken
meine Finger komisch
riecht komisch oder ich ganz anders als
die anderen
so schlecht also sauer wie er riecht
aber besser als sehr davor nochmal 16
oder was ja okay
Olivenöl aber finde ich geil meine
kleine Abwechslung wir machen mal einen
Zehner für das Olivenöl und probieren
werden wir es auf keinen Fall 17 sind
doch voll warm ich schwitze aus aber ich
glaube
das war ein gut Düringer kommt dieses
Mal mit einem Weißburgunder um die Ecke
kennst du den Unterschied zwischen einem
Grauburgunder und einem Weißburgunder
natürlich auf Gehrung und
Härtegrad bei einem klassischen
Waldbewohner ist auf jeden Fall milder
Leute auch explizit immer Leute
niemals gedacht dass ich das sage weiß
warum
alles klar Leute dann würde ich sagen
mann ich will frei für Türchen Nummer 19
ach wir haben natürlich die Nummer 12
nicht aufgemacht Mensch deswegen habe
ich noch gedacht dass wir nicht Halbzeit
gesagt haben so Halbzeit wir sind bei
der Nummer 12 sind wir gar nicht sicher
normal 12 guck mal und dann hast du was
cooles drin wir haben das einfach ein
Tee nee Kaffee
Royale
10 kg kosten 10 €. was ein Kilo kostet
21 Euro okay dann 2,50 € machen wir für
den Kaffee tschuldigung mit diesem
Zwischenfall jetzt sind wir bei Türchen
Nummer 18 Nummer
ah 18 video
aber an sich finde ich die Mischung
eigentlich ganz geil dafür für was ist
ne
ein paar Tees Kaffee alles so drinkables
doch eigentlich ganz geil
fünf Euro 90
Flocken
selber vom Thema ab sage ich dir ganz
ehrlich fein und knusprig das verstehe
ich nicht warum in dem Wein Kalender
Hashtag leute wenn ihr zur Timo
Community gehört
transition
falls 3,75€
. wow wow
Prost Leute ne
Weißburgunder ist besser
durchgeschüttet also wir sind jetzt in
den 20ern du hast gerade schon die
ersten 20 aufgemacht
21 ist ein wichtiges Türchen ab jetzt
darf man weltweit trinken außer
natürlich in den Staaten Ländern die
denken das ist haram wow ein Rotwein mit
einem
nicht mit einem Korken so sieht die
Flasche aus steht aber keinen so Pino
nur
ein kostet 10 Euro die Flasche das heißt
das hier ist unser teuerster Wein 5 €,
die Familie Perrin liefert einen roten
mit bärigen Frucht und sanftigen Abgang
Herkunftsregion Ron Frankreich das ist
ein französischer Timo der wird richtig
gut schmecken tolles einschenkgefühl
-1 - extrem
sauerfaktor ganz mit dem durchgebarbeit
22 Leute falls ihr sehen könnt ist es
hier drüben
des aufzumachen schwer wir sind ein
kleines Workout
nee ist das eingeblendeter Berg ich
glaube es nicht ne das ist einfach nur
naja aber warte aber warte warte warte
das ist cool sorry
stimmt 7 € unser vorletztes Türchen
morgen ist Weihnachten oh
okay das also oh da freue ich mich
eigentlich denken kann laufe ich bei
diesem Gewürzen vorbei und sehe diese
feine Welt Gewürze ne und dieses
Zitronenpfeffer hat mich immer schon
angelacht es ist wahrscheinlich
übertrieben aber warum Salz und Pfeffer
in einem Weingalerie versteht jetzt
Konzept nicht 5 € ja ich habe früher bei
Rewe mal gearbeitet drei Jahre wäre das
nicht weiß ich wusste es ich habe es
gewusst
ja und da bin ich echt immer in diesem
Pfeffer vorbei gelaufen das ist holt
gerade bei mir vielleicht ein bisschen
Emotionen Türchen Nummer 24 Leute das
letzte Türchen gesagt der Kalender
20 es ist Heiligabend du
rennst ein gutes Essen und du siehst
Mann ich habe kein Wein darf ich mal
ganz kurz zu meinem Adventskalender und
hole diesen Wein Trier der schon wieder
Mensch der ist aus 2017 oh ich fühle
mich schon ein bisschen
schlecht den aufzumachen drehen
warte mal für die Flasche kostet
Euro 95 wir haben hier ein Heavy Metal
Leute wir haben hier einen richtigen
heavy so laut 6 Euro also
und da benutzen wir unser neuen Freund
hier das sieht so
cool auch das designt hat ne muss man
sagen guck und dann packst du wirklich
so Kultur noch nie im Leben gesehen
guck mal wie langsam das auch rausläuft
und wie viel du mir rein gemacht hast
viel zu viel aber sieht cool aus oder so
cool aus
gefällt mir sehr gut macht irgendwie
direkt ein bisschen mehr Premium alles
ne der Warnhinweis von uns beiden kommt
ein bisschen spät aber trinkt wirklich
nicht alleine guckt darauf dass ihr
nicht zu viel trinkt Alkohol sollte
immer noch Freude bringen und nicht ein
Mittel zum Zweck sein um irgendwelche
Gefühle oder sonst was runterzudrücken
ne starte geh zum help
ist einfach auf mich meins der ist 5
Jahre alt
komplett falsche Mann um das zu testen
ich mag kein Wein ich bin nicht so Fan
von sowas ich glaube Leute die
wirklichen Wein mögen ne also wieder
draußen das wird bestimmt richtig guter
Tropfen gerade was war der beste Rotwein
des Abends wir hatten einen Favoriten
oder wenn ihr denkt ihr mögt kein
Rotwein dann probiert mal den weil dann
seid ihr wahrscheinlich so ähnlich wie
ich für alle die Rotwein mögen ist es
wahrscheinlich richtig scheiße war
wahrscheinlich dann eher so ein herben
haben keine Ahnung aber
sagen wir haben die Weine leider nicht
zu ihrer richtigen Temperatur getrunken
naja wie dem auch sei ich würde sagen
ihr habt einen guten Einblick bekommen
von diesem Kalender da war viel dabei
wir hatten Gewürze wir hatten Öle wir
hatten Vinos wir hatten weil Equipment
ja ja achso ich brauche ein
Taschenrechner Bruder 23 € 15 meine
Damen und Herren und dann haben wir noch
10 € Gutschein den zählen wir mal mit
dann haben wir ungefähr
20 € mehr als wir ausgegeben haben und
ich muss sagen ich finde den Kalender
echt gut also das ist der Wein das ist
natürlich jetzt nicht so ganz unser
Geschmack bzw sind wir jetzt hier nicht
so wie immer Freunde
wie bewertest du denn halt einfach ich
finde es gut dass das alles so Produkte
sind die du nicht sofort öffnen musst
die auch ja einfach rumstehen können ich
glaube halt die Zielgruppe ist halt
wirklich Rüdiger
anni würde sich auch darüber freuen mit
Timo zusammen ich glaube entweder ist es
ein so 40 Plus oder für Paare gut also
ähm vielen Dank an Timo den Special
Guest heute danke dass du das gemacht
dass ich weiß du würdest alles lieber
tun nein nichts lieber tun du würdest
alles alles